if you want to hang out and talk about
anime theories recommendations and other
fun stuff feel free to join us on
discord and twitch both links are in the
description what is up everybody its
Anna Mak here for anime uproar and in
this video we will be talking about
Durance true intentions and motivations
which have been finally revealed in
episode 130 of Dragon Ball super in
previous episodes we've gotten some
clues about Durin's past his philosophy
on life and the driving force behind his
commitment to become strong but an
episode 130 all the pretenses were
dropped and we finally saw who Jaron
really is and how far he is willing to
go in the name of his beliefs
the real jiren is very different from
what we were led to believe when he was
first introduced as a pride trooper and
a defender of justice there is a much
darker side to Jared and that is what we
will be talking about in this video if
you enjoyed the Dragon Ball super
content on this channel be sure to leave
a like to let me know if you're new to
the channel don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification bell and we
post daily anime content on Twitter and
Instagram so come and check us out at
anime uproar in episode 130 as he is
losing the upper hand against the
mastered ultra instinct Goku in battle
jiren loses his cool he becomes almost
desperate and he repeats once again that
he cannot lose no matter what cheerin
believes that strength is justice
strength is absolute everything is
meaningless without victory to be
defeated is to lose everything now it
might sound like gern is just saying
random things here because he is so
shocked and angry that he can't seem to
defeat Goku but in reality jiren is
revealing to us his entire outlook on
life his philosophy about justice we
know that the pride troopers and
especially topo like to talk a lot about
this idea of Justice doing what's right
protecting the innocent defeating
evildoers and so on and while the exact
definition of justice is a complicated
question that
has been debated for thousands of years
when we talk about justice this is
usually what we think of protecting the
innocent punishing evildoers and
fighting for what's right but an episode
130 Geron reveals that he doesn't
actually believe in this idea of justice
at all Kieran's commitment to the Pride
troopers and to defending justice was a
lie
during his showdown with Goku Jaron has
a flashback to when he lost his parents
and comrades at the hands of the
mysterious evildoer from his past and
this traumatic memory and the desire to
never let something like this happen
again drives him to unlock his hidden
power cheerin vows that no matter what
he will never lose because losing to him
is the worst thing in the world as he
says to be defeated is to lose
everything
Durin's tragic past shaped his outlook
on life his philosophy and the view of
justice that he now holds the thing that
he really believes in is the concept of
might makes right and what does this
mean
basically this means that there is no
right and wrong at all
there is no such thing as justice those
who are strong and have power determine
what is right and what is wrong they
decide what justice is because they are
strong and others are weak they force
everyone else to accept their rules
about what is right and what is wrong
those who are strong create their own
definition of justice and this
definition is designed to benefit them
the strong define justice and what is
right and wrong in a way that suits them
and there is nothing that the weak can
do about it simply put it is the idea
that history is written by the victors
those who win decide what is true what
is right and what is just that is why
jiren says strength is justice if I am
strong and you are weak I get to decide
what is right and what is wrong and you
have to accept it if you don't I can
destroy you because I am stronger we can
definitely see how jiren came to believe
that might makes right he has a tragic
past where an evildoer destroyed his
family and kill
his friends when they tried to stand up
to him because he was strong and they
were weak the ideas of good and evil
right and wrong just and unjust did not
matter to the evildoer he was strong and
he did what he wanted his victims were
weaker and so they suffered jiren saw
this and he came to the conclusion that
justice doesn't matter the idea of
justice and right and wrong is not going
to stop a villain from hurting an
innocent person the only thing that will
stop him is strength and this is why
jiren believed that strength is the only
justice because strength is absolute you
can debate about the definition of
justice all you want but words cannot
protect you from fists the only thing
that can protect you is to get stronger
than your enemy the really interesting
thing about episode 130 is the fact that
in this episode jeera and Goku are not
only fighting physically their personal
philosophies are clashing as well
because of his belief that strength is
justice and that might makes right jiren
doesn't trust anyone but himself
he thinks that putting faith in others
is foolish because the only thing that
you can trust is your own strength on
the other hand as Crillon points out
from the stands Goku always springs back
no matter what
Krillin piccolo Vegeta Gohan Android 18
and all of the other members of universe
7 believe in Goku they place their faith
in Goku cheerin asks Goku how he keeps
getting up after getting beaten so many
times and Goku tells him that it is
because all of the people that he cares
about are trusting in him they believe
in him and depend on him and because of
the faith that they put in him he never
backs down the people that believe in
Goku give him strength to go on
Goku knows that the reason he is where
he is today the reason he became as
strong as he did is because he had the
support of all of his friends along the
way and this made him stronger some of
his friends started out as enemies and
they fought each other and trained each
other and became stronger together
jaren is furious when he hears this
because it is so different from his own
beliefs jiren asks who cares about
friendship
who cares about trusting in others to
accept that these things matter would be
to deny everything he'd ever been all of
his own beliefs jiren warns Goku that
the power you get from placing your
faith and others is easily erased and
then he does something that I really
didn't see coming
jiren shoots an energy blast not at Goku
but at the stands where Goku's friends
are watching the fight this energy blast
this act of aggression reveals Durance
true nature the real jiren and how far
he is willing to go to prove his point
goku manages to deflect the blast and
save his friends and we could argue that
even if goku didn't get there in time
the gods of destruction and angels would
have stopped it but we can't be 100%
sure so what jiren did was truly extreme
jiren put the lives of innocent people
at risk just to prove to goku that
strength is all that matters just to
prove that strength and power determine
who is right and who is wrong and things
like justice friendship and trust are
meaningless in the face of overwhelming
force if we think about this in terms of
international relations
Durin's view is actually pretty common
and even realistic if a stronger country
attacks a weaker country the weaker
country can talk about how the attack
violates international law how it is
morally wrong and unjust but if the
stronger country doesn't care about
those things then those things are
meaningless words and complaints will
not protect the weaker country from
their enemies tanks and fighter planes
so I can kind of see where jiren is
coming from but on the other hand the
story of Dragon Ball is the story of how
enemies can become friends and how
others can inspire us to train harder
and to fight against all odds to protect
the people we care about
Goku even says that he is not a hero of
justice or anything and of course the
Pride troopers used to talk a big game
about being heroes of justice but Goku
says that he will not forgive those who
try to hurt the people he cares about so
this truly is a clash of philosophies
the philosophy of might makes right and
the idea that your own strength is all
that matters
versus the philosophy that in life we
depend on others and that we need our
friends and the people we care about to
make us better and stronger people
personally I really enjoyed the fight
itself but I also enjoyed this
additional philosophical layer to the
showdown between Goku and jiren I have
to say that I was really surprised to
see Jaron try to attack go who's friends
in the stands that to me really revealed
the gerunds true nature beneath the calm
and quiet exterior there is a much
darker side to Jaron and he is willing
to do whatever it takes even Foote
innocent people in danger to prove his
point and justify his philosophy this
really does add an extra layer to
jaren's character he is not the hero of
Justice that he claimed to be in fact in
some ways he is the exact opposite of
that but let me know what you guys think
did your opinion of Jaron change after
episode 130 and what do you think about
the clash of philosophies do you agree
with jiren that might makes right and
that the only thing you can depend on is
your own strength or do you agree with
Goku that other people can make you
stronger and that you should depend on
your friends for support let me know
down in the comments if you enjoyed this
video I want to see more like it be sure
to leave a like to let me know if you
are new to the channel don't forget
subscribe and hit that notification bell
big THANK YOU to Cuusoo Murray for
sending me another one of his awesome
fan art of mastered ultra instinct Goku
I will link to his social media in the
description be sure to check him out and
show him some love if you want to have
your art featured in one of our future
videos be sure to follow us on Twitter
and Instagram at anime uproar as always
thank you all so much for watching and
until next time see us space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]